ce sera dans les bacs ou plutôt sur les
plateformes digitales demain vendredi 15
mai yoga un premier ep pour vous sommeil
bonsoir bonsoir
alors comment tu avez vous déjà en cette
semaine de déconfinement ben c'est une
semaine un peu festive rapport aux
déconfinement et puis aussi un rapport
ben à la sortie de cette paix de mon
premier en fin de mon deuxième clip
pardon aussi
donc voilà plein d'événements assez
sympa alors peut-être titre pour ce
premier projet musical dont la sortie
était prévue plutôt pourquoi avoir
repoussé cette sortie au vendredi 15 mai
c'est en quelque sorte votre cadeau de
déconfinement c'est un peu ça oui bah ya
le fait que par rapport à la crise bat
ducobu de 19
on avait une release party qui était
prévu et une grosse soirée avec une
bonne salle mais bon bah forcément les
concerts est un compromis
il a fallu se diriger vers une sortie et
plus digital en fait et donc qui
interviendra demain vendredi
cette année nous vous êtes restés
confinés pendant deux mois à versailles
au foyer jeunes travailleurs dans lequel
vous résidez ce qu'elle vous a permis de
réfléchir peut-être de changer l'artiste
que vous êtes est ce que ça vous a
permis un petit peu de réflexion cette
période de confinement oui complètement
c'est vrai que on s'est dirigé vers
quelque chose qui était plus digital les
réseaux en fait ça a été tout naturel et
on a mis en place des challenge on a
fait des vidéos de kober aussi sur
youtube
donc voilà ça nous a permis vraiment de
communiquer avec une fanbase
bacon n'avait pas suffisamment
sollicités avant quoi avec eux qui
étaient très contentes de découvrir
toutes ces choses qu'on avait envie de
partager avec eux en fait avec quatre
titres pour cette paix dont dis moi
pourquoi dont le clip est sorti il y à
peu on écoute tout de suite un extrait
[Musique]
je ne cultive pas
je mets plus vivre comme ça
moi
je fermais
manger sur un terre disposés sur un ca
et
mais j'espère qu'en jeu
oh non je suis le
[Musique]
dis moi pourquoi un clip ensoleillé
sommeil tourner dans votre martinique
des sonorités entraînantes c'est ça
votre style pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas ou vous avez déjà reçu
ici en plateau mais pour ceux qui ne
vous connaissent pas c'est ça c'est un
style entraînant sommeil oui c'est ça
les paroles peuvent être nostalgique ou
un peu profondes aspirer à la réflexion
mais c'est vrai que j'aime garder un
style très très entraînant à une musique
très dynamique c'est quelque chose qui
me tient vraiment à coeur
il ya 4 e titre sur cette paie ce que
sur les trois autres on est dans la même
veine
oui alors il ya sept relief quand même
hein on a des morceaux qui sont un peu
plus triste des morceaux qui sont très
joyeux comme le dernier morceau index
majeur voilà donc c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup de relief et donc c'est déjà le
deuxième clip qui sort de sept pays a
dit moi pourquoi il y en avait aussi un
autre qui était sorti auparavant
oui absolument c'était amy attend qu'ils
étaient donc du coup le premier single
qui était paru en novembre novembre 2019
et un clip bas un très très beau clip
tourné en bulgarie une très belle
opportunité aussi et vous prévoyez quel
autre pays pour les prochains clips et
ben franchement si ça peut perdre et
j'ai le plus possible c'est vraiment
super c'est une belle aventure sommeil
et j'espère que ça va continuer et
prendre de l'ampleur et justement
l'objectif avec cette sortie de paix
c'est la poursuite de votre projet
musical
on avait discuté sur ce plateau du début
de ce projet cessé de le poursuivre
c'est une nouvelle étape finalement oui
complètement bas c'est vraiment là je ne
monte pas manquer ce que c'est sommeil
avec un premier ep et c'est une base
pour construire encore plus ce projet et
proposer des choses qui seront encore
plus proche de ce que je suis vraiment
aidé ce que j'ai à proposer quoi est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter dernière
question alors bas que le live
reprennent assez vite parce qu'on a très
envie de retrouver le chemin de la scène
et puis voilà un nouvel album en
préparation donc voilà votre première
paye aux gars disponible donc à partir
de demain vendredi 15 mai sur les
plateformes digitales merci sommeil
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous